okay let's get started thanks to the
organizers and welcome buddy you asked
me to give the first lecture in the boot
camp so I started thinking where should
I start from the program is about
polynomials so let's talk about
polynomials does anybody know who
invented polynomial was the first
mathematician to actually formulate the
concept of a polynomial
there might be some debate about this
one possible answer is dear fantasy
roman empire mathematician developed a
certain notation for polynomials
although only pop up to power of six he
didn't have know they used letters and
they only went up to six and he studied
equalities which today would be called
dear pantheon equations polynomials with
integer coefficients and asking for
integer roots so in some sense
he was the first mathematician to talk
about polynomials although he didn't
really consider them as a as a
mathematical object the first
mathematician and i had to look it up
that I didn't know this who actually
define a polynomial as an object with
arbitrary powers unbounded X to the N
was relatively obscure Islamic scholar
all qiraji in fact iranian-born
encouraged and he actually defined
polynomials general powers of x as far
as we know he seems to be the first
mathematician to actually do that he was
a follower of the more famous alvarez me
who also worked on algebra but he didn't
talk about when O'Neill's he actually
gave solutions to the quadratic equation
among other things and all karate was
his followers so this seems to be the
first place were actually polynomials up
here in europe oh of course dessert dark
ages if mathematics didn't pick up until
the sixteenth century let's say with the
Italian school culminating and the
resolution of cubic and quartic
equations Cardno published closed form
solutions and he also started talking
about complex numbers a follower of
Cardinal was Francois Fiat mentioning
him because he first one to develop
certain equations relating coefficients
of a polynomial and the roots which will
be it relevant for this lecture
particular that Isaac Newton actually
took things further and they will
develop other identities which are today
called Newton's identities also although
it turns out that they were actually
discovered a little bit earlier by
another French mathematician as well so
these are the beginnings now let me
mention the fundamental theorem about
bueno meals which is that every
polynomial with complex coefficients has
a complex root and that's the beauty of
field of complex numbers that we can
take any polynomial and we can factor it
into factors X minus lambda J so this
works very nicely in complex numbers but
if you ask for real roots as you know
they don't always exist some point on it
was have real roots some and it's a nice
property of a polynomial if all its
roots are real so this is what we call a
real rooted polynomial polynomial which
can be factored into linear factors with
real roots a polynomial of degree n so
there might be multiple roots that's
fine but all the roots should be real
graphically real root 2.0 Mills all the
way up and down and times except for the
case of multiple roots that we usually
have to be careful about and so let me
say a few other things we also know that
there's no postponed solution using
radicals for polynomials of degree more
than four but roots can be computed very
successfully numerically and what will
be useful here are relations between the
coefficients and the roots all those
roots themselves cannot be expressed
closed form in general there are
relations which will be useful for us so
remember the the French mathematician
that I've mentioned in
century from Swabia he came up with
these relations which are pretty simple
directly from the expression for a
polynomial as a product of X minus
lambda J where lambda J are the roots
you can derive the following that
coefficient a a and minus one is minus
the summation the roots and the next
coefficient a and minus two the
summation over pairs of products of
pairs of roots the third one would be a
minus summation over triples of roots
and so on and the constant term is plus
minus the product so these are called
gets identities so knowing the roots
it's easy to say what the coefficients
are first Direction is more complicated
what Newton did was he notice that if
you look at the summation of the power
such as certain powers of all the roots
let's say case powers this is a quantity
that we can actually express in terms of
the coefficient so as I already
mentioned the summation of the roots is
just minus the coefficient a and minus 1
so here I'm assuming the polynomial is
monic there could be some leading
coefficient as well but for now let's
just assume it's one coefficient in
front of X be honest one so the
summation of the roots is is easy it's
just minus a and minus one and you can
continue like this so now let's let's
think about the summation of the squares
of the roots how do you express the
summation of the squares well so if you
take the sum of the roots you squared
that the summation lambda J the whole
thing squared then you will get the
squares and also some cross terms so
then we subtract them out and we know
that that's that's exactly the Abe and
minus 2 coefficient the summation over
pairs of roots the products of pairs of
roots can be expressed in terms of a and
minus two so the summation of the roots
weird also has a nice expression it's a
and minus one squared minus 2a you can
continue like this the summation of the
true cubed can be expressed in terms of
a and minus 1 a and minus 2 and minus
there's a general formula which is what
we call Newton's identity the summation
of the roots to the power of K can be
computed recursively using the
coefficients am i that we computed
earlier there's a nice formula so so
this is something that we can do
efficiently ok we can compute the
summation of the roots of the power of K
this is a useful consequence from the
point of view of a computer scientist
you could ask if I give you a polynomial
with real coefficients can you actually
tell if it has real roots or no or it's
not clear because we don't know how to
compute their roots but there's a nice
criterion for saying whether the
polynomial is real rooted or not and
this is known as the Hermit Silvestre
theorem so if I give you a polynomial
and now suppose it's written in this
form a product of X minus lambda J
though we don't know what the languages
are but the statement is that it's
really rooted if and only if a certain
matrix is positive semi-definite and the
matrix is formed by taking these power
sums of roots and and sub something I'm
sub I plus J minus 2 in the matrix such
that the entries only depend on I plus J
and you just plug in these power Psalms
from this n by n matrix and then you
check whether that matrix is positive
semi-definite so the claim is that this
is if and only if this will be actually
one of our exercises so I will postpone
it for now but the nice corollary for us
is that this is a tractable problem
computationally testing whether a
polynomial is really rooted
Newton noticed a few other nice
properties of real rooted polynomials
one is when you look at a real rooted
polynomial with non-negative
coefficients the positive coefficients
and they always form a unimodal sequence
so when you look at the coefficients
they go up and then they go down and not
only that they actually form a lot
concave ratios between successive
coefficients are monotonic so this is
this is a phenomenon which appears in
different areas of community oryx in
this setting is it's pretty simple to
explain why this happens and we will do
it right now but this actually
foreshadows other much more difficult
results which will fact that the certain
combinatorial sequence is unimodal or
moreover la concave when that happens it
usually means something pretty
interesting o cases it's very hard to
prove in this setting you can actually
prove something a little bit stronger he
proved that even when you divide these
coefficients by the binomial
coefficients they still form LOC concave
sequence so in some sense it's at least
as block concave as at the bought
binomial coefficients the binomial
coefficients of course would be the
coefficients of the polynomial 1 plus X
to the N so that so why is this true so
actually the proof is interesting so now
we have to talk about polynomials a
little bit more so let's say that I have
two polynomials polynomial P of degree
polynomial Q
we say that the roots of Pew interlace
the roots of if the roots are ordered in
this fashion that they alternate on the
real line so illustrates how this might
happen when you look at the real line
you will see blue root red root blue
roots only SEC inequalities could be
actually qualities that's
one way and this might happen in which
this might happen is that you take a
point or meal and then you differentiate
it so let's just think about that that's
that's to think about and also a useful
fact that if P is real rooted then the
derivative of P is also going to be real
rooted and its roots interlace those of
P so let's just think about the case
where P has n distinct roots multiple
roots still work you just have to think
about it a little bit more carefully so
if P has n distinct roots then what
happens when you look at the intervals
between successive roots for example
here the blue polynomial goes negative
then it comes back to the real line so
it must have an extremely point
somewhere between the two between every
two consecutive roots there must be an
extremal point of the blue polynomial
and this extremal point is a root of the
derivative which is the red polynomial
right so between every two consecutive
roots the derivative has a root blue
polynomial has n what's a distinct roots
so the red polynomial has n minus 1
distinct roots one in each interval
between two consecutive so this is what
happens for the derivative more
generally this is one of one of the
operations that you can do on a real
root atop polynomial and it still
remains real rooted so this will be a
running theme here what are the
operations that you can apply to a real
root is polynomial more later stable
polynomials which I'm not defining it
what they are but the the important
thing is what are the operations that
you can apply to these polynomials and
they still remain real rooted and taking
the derivative is the first such
operation this states that this is what
you can do
with multiple roots you have to think
about it a little bit more carefully but
he will see that it still works for
example if you have multiplicity two
then the Blue Point ami would just touch
there a line so there are two roots
there and then the derivative would have
a single root at the same location so
just think about it and the statement is
still true let me just skip that for now
another operation that you can do is you
can reverse the order of the
coefficients so you can take any
polynomial you can do that with any
polynomial with coefficients from a 0
through a N and just reverse the order
so a zero takes the place of an
algebraically what does that mean we're
taking P plug in 101 over X and
multiplied by X to the N to this hole so
do what I just said it will reverse the
order of coefficients so the claim is
that this is another operation which
preserves real rootedness and the roots
of the new polynomial are going to be
just 1 over the roots of the old
polynomial one thing you have to be
careful about what if P has some roots
equal to 0 well it turns out that those
will just disappear and actually in that
case the degree of the polynomial will
go down because if you have let's say P
is P of X is just equal to X make it
some V of X is equal to X then this is 1
over x times X so the new polynomial is
1 so if if P has some roots equal to 0
and also just come out disappear and the
degree of the point on oh a decreases
but apart from that all the roots of the
new polynomial are going to be 1 over
the roots of P which is easy to see just
by substitution right 1 over X here so
so that's what happens
if the if P has this expression product
of X minus alpha J then the new
polynomial is going to be the product of
1 minus alpha J so the new polynomial
has again real roots and it has the
number of roots corresponding to its
degree 0 roots just disappeared so the
number of roots that disappeared is
exactly by how much to degree went down
so you still have all the roots it's ok
so this is our second operation that we
can perform all right so so now let's
actually prove Newton's qualities and I
think more than the specific proof here
what is important is the idea here so
the idea is that we want to say
something about a triple of coefficients
we have a polynomial ok and we have this
triple of coefficient we want to do that
for every K but for some particular K I
want to say something about the
relationship of a K minus 1 a K and a K
plus 1 ok so the way I'm gonna do that
is that I'm going to massage the
polynomial in certain ways using my
operations in such a way that I extract
some quadratic polynomial which has only
these three coefficients so I can say
something about them but the operations
that I use are are exactly those real
rootedness preserving operations so
throughout the process the polynomial
will remain real rooted and this will
foreshadow many other arguments it will
come up in this bootcamp and in this
area where you want to say something you
want to prove let's say that a certain
point on a 3 rooted to start from
something that you know to be real
rooted and massage it using your
operations until you get what you want
and what you what you get is guaranteed
to be real rooted or stable polynomial
so let's do it here just to see how that
might work so we have this degree
and polynomial and I want to kill
everything except for these three
coefficients so first let's
differentiate it until all the stuff
below a K disappears so just
differentiate it K minus 1 times and
this will bring the relevant
coefficients to the bottom of the
polynomial the constant term linear term
quadratic term and then we have some
other stuff above that and we get some
coefficients which you don't have to
worry about too much some factorial so
now I would like to kill all the
coefficients above the quadratic term
right so I'm gonna reverse the order of
coefficients by using the operation that
I described this will bring the other
coefficients right here but we'll bring
them to the top of the polynomial the
top three powers and then we have some
junk here that we don't care about so
let's differentiate again until all this
junk disappears so differentiate and
minus K minus 1 times and all that
remains is a quadratic polynomial right
we destroyed all the terms up here and
we obtained a certain quadratic
polynomial which contains the
coefficients that we care about so now
what do we know the only information and
the important information is that this
point nominal is really rooted all the
operations were preserving real routines
it's a quadratic polynomial so that's a
simple thing how do you check a
quadratic polynomial it's really rooted
the discriminant should be non-negative
so just write down the discriminant of
this point omiyo there's a bunch of
factorials here your arrange things
nicely and you get exactly this
inequality this is Newton's inequality
officiants divided by the binomial
coefficients are
so so this is the template that will
come up later now let me talk about
something a little bit different there's
a nice connection between real Ruthie's
polynomials and distributions of
independent Bernoulli random variables
this will actually have some surprising
so the statement is that a real rooted
polynomial with non-negative
coefficients always captures the
distribution of the summation of a bunch
of independent Bernoulli random
variables in the sense that the
coefficients a K are just the
probabilities that the summation of the
independent Bernoulli random variables
zero one random variables is exactly K
is running from zero to and you have n
variables they sum up to something
between 0 and n and the statement is
that this is a if and only if
polynomials sorry root you're rooted if
and only if it captures this kind of
distribution or non-negative
coefficients
so why is this true again not too
complicated so if the coefficients have
this form if a K is the probability that
for certain collection of Bernoulli
random variables the summation of YJ is
equal to K then well we can write the
polynomial in this form the summation of
AJ X to the J so this is an expectation
of this expression is the moment
generating function X to the summation
of YJ the expectation of that is exactly
my polynomial right if the variables are
independent then we can break it down
into a product of expectations each of
these expectations is 1 minus PJ that's
the probability that the variable is 0 +
pj x x pj is the probability that so
it's a product of linear terms linear
factors with real coefficients so so
it's a real rooted polynomial
implication you can also do it the other
way so if P is real rooted then you can
write it as a product now it's a real
rooted polynomial with non-negative
coefficients normalized to sum up to 1
you know I forgot to say that earlier so
it cannot have any strictly positive
roots right it's not always efficient so
all the roots are non positive so we can
write it in this form it's a product of
X to X plus BJ and BJ are some
non-negative real these are actually the
roots with a negative sign we also have
this normalization so so the factor in
front is just 1 minus the product 1 plus
Beach
so the polynomial is in this form
product of X plus BJ over 1 plus BJ and
that can be viewed exactly as a
generating function of the summation of
independent Bernoulli variables if you
accept the probability PJ to be 1 over 1
plus BJ this is exactly what you get ya
x over 1 plus V J which is PJ plus 1 -
that's exactly in this form it works
both ways
so just remember real rooted polynomials
with non-negative coefficients are
exactly the generating functions of
summations of independent Bernoulli
random variables this is an interesting
implication let me say now ok one
corollary is that these probabilities
from a law concave sequence by using the
probably other ways to prove it but it's
it's a nice fact let me let me say a
little bit about some combinatorial
situations where real rooted polynomials
come on the reason why why we are having
this semester is that because some point
oh me oh sorry root it just when you
write the formula because point on is
that there is an interesting coming
after all situations happen to be let me
give you two examples which will come up
later in the butakov I'm not going to
prove now that they're really rooted but
they're both pretty important the first
example is the matching polynomial the
matching point normal can be written in
different forms this is what is
sometimes called a matching defect
polynomial in this form we have for each
matching a contribution where you have X
to the power corresponding to the number
of vertices which are not covered by the
matching so it's the number of vertices
minus twice the cardinality
also contributions have alternating
signs parity of the size of the matching
so let's call this the matching
polynomial and the claim that this is a
real rooted polynomial now this is much
less obvious if you stay to like that
very interesting fact which will have
important implications the second
polynomial that I want to mention is the
spanning tree polynomial so now I'm
doing something maybe slightly strange
here if you just write down the basic
spanning tree polynomial that would be
the summation over spanning trees
analogous to this x2 the number of edges
in a spanning tree that's not a very
interesting polynomial that's just the
number of spanning trees times X to the
N minus 1 the spanning tree for a
polynomial can be also written in a
multivariate form where you have a
different variable for each edge this
will come up later because for now I
don't I don't have the language to say
what is interesting about it but let's
let's tweak the polynomial a little bit
and let's define it in this form I fix
some set of edges F for example this
could be the edges in a certain cut
consider a fixed cut
I'll let F be exactly the edges across
the car the polynomial is going to count
the number of edges that each tree has
across this cut for each spanning tree I
take X 2 the number of edges about the
tree
so this is a polynomial now a more
interesting polynomial univariate
polynomial and the claim is that this
polynomial is also real rooted that's
not obvious the proofs will come up
later so now here here's an interesting
fact so if you look at any graph take a
uniformly random spanning tree now look
at how many edges P I'm using T for the
set of edges okay how many edges this
tree contains in a certain fixed set
again for example it cut how many edges
does it have across this so this is a
random variable right I put random tree
it might have different veggies across
this cut so the claim is that this is
actually a summation of independent
Bernoulli variables now that sounds
pretty suspicious right because
certainly the edges in a tree don't
appear independently sounds like a
contradiction in mathematics but
actually it's a true fact so the the
Bernoulli variables exist it's not clear
how they're actually related to the
edges of the graph but the distribution
exists you can also always take this
random variable which has a certain
distribution you can break it down as a
summation of independent Bernoulli
variables so you can actually say a lot
about that distribution it behaves like
yeah you have turn off bounce and
whatnot it it's it's this form of random
variable although these Bernoulli
variables are kind of magical I don't
know if somebody here has more intuition
about it shyam it's a little bit
mysterious what are these Bernoulli
variables because they certainly don't
correspond to the appearance of
individual edges in that cut those are
not independent generally
but it is true so let's let's prove it I
mean using the fact that the spanning
tree polynomial is real rooted this will
be pretty easy so T sub F is the
generating function for the number of
edges that is spanning tree has in F and
we can also write the total number of
spanning trees as t1 so the expectation
of X to the Z is just 1 over the total
number of spanning trees times the
summation of the older spanning trees x2
the number of edges that tea contains in
this particular set so it's just
spanning tree polynomial subject to F
over spanning tree point Gnomeo this is
just a number T te of 1 it's just the
total number of spanning tree so this
whole thing is this is a real rooted
polynomial by the claim that I made
which and it's also normalized in the
sense that the coefficients sum up to 1
is just because when you plug in 1 you
will get 1 so it's a really rooted point
omiyo and it can be expressed the
distribution can be expressed as a
summation of independent Bernoulli
okay so I see that I actually went
pretty fast faster than I expected so we
have lots of time for I will slow down
now yeah we have some tricky problems on
the homework on the problem sheet so
let's take a quick break do that yeah
let's have a little break now and then
we will decide what to do and meanwhile
look at the problems see how this goes